you wanna know what's really amazing i
was reading this op-ed on the economy
back in 2019 because the economy was was
was booming it was huge i mean from my
personal experience i told the story
when we were setting up our first studio
the lady at the furniture store said
2019 was the best year of my life
people were making money our contractor
who was doing work in the ed was like
the best year i've had so i'm reading
this op-ed and they said that all of
these things the leftists claim they
wanted four-day work weeks
higher wages paid vacation family leave
are happening thanks to capitalism and a
good economy the government need not
force it the machine is working the
policies are working and then what
happens
these leftists say we demand these
things
so when these things start happening
naturally they vote for joe biden who
reverses all of the things that trump
did and then end all of that really
great stuff and make a terrible economy
occur so the the thing is
if you have good economic policy the
economy starts working starts it's
coming back the machine starts churning
you get lubricate the gears get them
going and when you have bad policy you
put gum in the works things slow down
and fall apart these leftists seem to
think i know people should be paid more
money i know we'll force people to pay
them more money as if that manifests
money or economic value or labor value
it doesn't yeah so when they came in
with the hammer to try and bash the
system which was already doing what they
wanted they broke it
yeah let me uh introduce a concept here
which i think would be useful to your
viewers
they call them service sector refugees
it's kind of at the heart of the
pandemic shock that we're facing that's
going to create stagflation which is
simultaneous inflation and slow growth
or recession
and and if you think about what the
pandemic has done it's been like a
neutron bomb to our major metropolitan
areas if you think about it it hit it
hits like the the core foundation of
major cities it's like the mass transit
it's the entertainment districts but
most of all it's a high-rise
office buildings right and so we've gone
from a world where in new york or dallas
or chicago
the high-rise buildings were at 90
percent occupancy rate or higher now
that down like like to
kamala's approval rating like 29 30
stuff like that now think about this
it's like the white collar folks to to
your point as to who's like winning in
the pandemic economy the white collar
folks are sitting out in the in the
burbs right commuting on their on their
little
ipads or whatever they've got they're
living they're living okay right uh
although they might have to have tofu
for for turkey but that's another story
but but but those people who used to be
part of the eco structure of the cities
the janitors in the buildings uh the
trucks outside the the the food trucks
the beauticians this and the other thing
they don't have anywhere to go and
moreover they don't have the skills
to transit so we've got this weird thing
tim where you got like
10 million or so people unemployed
and 10 million or so
job openings
that is weird and so i get back to the
central tenets of the trump
administration which is by american
higher american if we don't if we don't
build more of what we consume here those
service and train those help train those
people those service sector refugees are
simply uh going to fade away into into
oblivion um and by the way i mean the
millennials um as as bannon loves to
point out on the war room uh
are turning into like modern day surfs
like you're not gonna own a car you're
not gonna own a home but you know you
can put that the virtual reality thing
on your head and your life looks pretty
good there for a while where you stone
out on exactly so maui wowie i would
love to ask you this because in the
beginning of trump's presidency he was
kind of battling with the federal
reserve he was clashing heads with the
federal reserve obviously the federal
reserve has been printing money out of
thin air that's why this this kind of
promotion of gmo monsanto soybeans is
absolutely ridiculous they shouldn't be
giving out nutritional advice they
should stop printing money out of thin
air but what was going on with the trump
administration with of course them just
literally printing money during the
pandemic and giving it to all the hedge
funds giving it to all the wall street
bankers giving them a huge bailout well
another shameless plug for in trump time
but there is a great story about jerome
powell in there and it goes something
like this
so um it comes time to appoint a new fed
chairman it was either going to be janet
yellen give her another term or somebody
else right and so
treasury secretary steve mnuchin who i
uh who i state flat out in the interrupt
time book if he had never come to the
administration donald trump would still
be president wow this guy did so
breaking news here too this guy did so
much damage but one of the things he did
was he was the guy who recommended jay
powell get appointed right and he did it
under the assumption because steve's a
control freak he thought he can control
jay powell now
he did jerome powell did something that
that is kind of contrary to what you
just said but i'll come back to you
being right what what we were doing with
our four points of that economic compass
i described earlier is we were able to
grow much more faster than the biden
obama regime
and do so without inflation okay the
only reason why the fed should raise
interest rates or tighten the money
supply is if there's any hint of
inflation what jerome powell did that
sob
he
ran contractionary monetary policy in
the middle of the beautiful trump boom
under the false assumption that somehow
there was going to be inflation so in
our time on our watch
as i talk about in the book he was too
contractionary we could have hit four
percent growth instead of three percent
growth and that's that's a that's a
million job difference okay so fast
forward now right it's like like
he is biden's guy now he's auditioning
for the job what does biden want biden
wants easy money to stimulate the
economy but what powell is doing is
contrary again to the facts in evidence
tim as he starts doing all the stuff
you're talking about and in terms of
biden undoing what trump did that's
provoking all manner of inflation you
add to that to pandemic shocks and by
and basically you go let me go back to
the 70s the 70s stagflation came about
because of profligate fiscal policy
check that box here with all the
congress is doing what arthur burns did
for nixon in monetary policy as the
chairman of the fed was to print money
and be too expansionary that's exactly
what jay powell's doing around check
that box and then what kicked off the
stagflation was the cost push food and
energy price shocks
of the 70s and we got the same thing
here and by the way you mentioned this
earlier tim and you were absolutely
right if energy prices go up guess what
food prices go up because things like
fertilizer which are energy driven
go up and by the way delivering the food
and other things go up and so
powell is he's a pox on this world and
the fact that we're going to see him for
another term
i mean
trump couldn't wait to get rid of that
guy we sat around scheming all the time
about how if we could take him out
before his term was up and whenever i
wanted to troll that friggin mnuchin in
the oval i'd look at the boss and say
boss who was that who wanted jay powell
at the fed
so
the other thing too is it's not just
inflation it's shrink flation where
products get smaller
but now we actually we have this story i
mean from timcast.com and it and i got
to tell you you know
this is typically not something i think
would be a big story but look at this
general mills to raise prices by 20
percent
20
yeah that is massive so you want to talk
about your kids having cereal in the
morning you know what really really
grinds my gears when i've been saying
over and over again for the past several
years like you need to stand up for what
you believe in now you need to get out
there you need to advocate for for what
you what you want to see in this world
we peaceful persuasive resourceful and i
get people saying like if i speak up at
my job then i'll lose my job and you
don't understand i got kids to feed
tell me now as the food shortages with
the price increases with the shrink
inflation and they're gonna they're
gonna raise the price your rice chex
your cheerios the kid wakes up for a
bowl of cereal and now you're wondering
why it's 20 more but not only that the
boxes are smaller and you're buying
twice as often and the food banks are
reporting that they're even having a
hard time feeding people because of the
inflation because of the supply and
change shortages so so peter i was going
to ask you
i'm always looking for the silver lining
here it's like your parents will need to
buy fewer diapers because they won't be
able to feed the kids
wait wait there's one more point there
you don't got to worry about uh buying
new clothes for your kids when they when
they get bigger yeah they're not going
to grow as they don't eat thank you very
much we do have an obesity crisis but
peter how bad does this get where where
does this oh oh this is this is what i'm
concerned about and again i get back to
lydia's question and point it's like
got a lot of miles on this bod i've
never seen it as bad this is like the
70s on steroids and so
so the way the 70s evolved that
literally
as we came in
from
it started with lyndon johnson in 68
with the refusal of choosing between the
vietnam war expenditures and the great
society okay there's this concept in
economics called guns versus butter it's
like you have to choose one or the other
in some combination in order to maintain
the budget it's like lbj was that we're
not going to do it we're going to do
both right so that's what that was the
fiscal stimulus that began
the whole whole process and and then so
it it's this whole stagnation didn't end
until 1981
and the way it ended was was brutal
in 1980 when reagan ran against carter
there was this thing called the misery
index it was inflation rate plus
unemployment and it was 20
by the time that election rolled around
mortgage rates were like 13 and 15
percent i mean this is like stuff that's
not in your the people who are viewing
and listening to the show can't even
imagine this because they've been they
grew they've grown up in an era of like
two three four percent mortgage rates no
no no no this like they were like 12 and
15 percent now my parents tell me this
yes they're like when you were a little
kid it was like 12 yeah it's crazy stuff
so the way the way
it was fixed
uh and this is instructive was it was in
two ways paul volcker came along
um as federal reserve chairman never
confused paul volcker with jerome powell
and he induced the mother of all
recessions to ring inflationary
expectations out of the economy and the
only reason why that worked is because
reagan came along and did all the
structural kind of changes that we've
been talking about guys and and that
basically reset the economy and and then
we went off on our 80s boom but but
but
that'll be a hard trick to redo
because it requires both a smart fed
chairman and somebody as president who
understands kind of the structural
changes this could go on for a decade i
mean we're at 28 trillion i think is the
deficit right now he's looking at
printing three trillion more to put it
to 31 how do you with the amount of
having to pay uh interest on that i
don't see it ever being able to come
back from this at this point where it's
like other than like um i don't know
economic
uh default or something like we'll
default on the us dollar and create a
new currency or something this is like
pelosi's uh
hail mary and big go brand into the
world here because if she gets away
with this latest bill this last piece of
the multi-trillion dollar
pipe dream progressive socialist marxist
cut a puzzle because there's nothing in
that bill that will strengthen the
economy to be clear it's mostly a
redistribution and it's a subsidy to
china because they're all the ones that
are going to be providing the electric
vehicle stuff okay let's be clear if
they are able to get this one across the
finish line
um you're absolutely right that this
this will be with us
and and our children and our
grandchildren forever so there's a lot a
lot at stake here and it's like i think
right now
we're virtually assured um of the
republicans taking back the house but it
may be too late but the other thing i'll
say about that is like
right now i'm a trump guy right i'm a
mega guy i'm a deplorables guy right but
there is a there's a battle in the
republican party itself
uh between the the rhino
corporatist party of davos republicans
represented by mitch mcconnell kevin
mccarthy liz cheney ben sass pat those
folks mitt romney versus the trumpers
who really want things like secure
borders fair trade buy american
manufacturing here and if we lose that
battle if we if we win the house
in in 22 and mcconnell and mccarthy are
still leaders we've lost the house
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time